Traduttore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Buongiorno a tutti.
Io mi chiamo Ezio,
e oggi vi racconterò di connessioni,
connessioni tra nuovi soggetti
e nuovi oggetti di apprendimento,
connessioni che scaturiscono dall'ascolto.
Dall'ascolto delle nuove generazioni
che ho la fortuna di vivere,
tutti i giorni, al lavoro e in famiglia.
Che lavoro faccio?
Lavoro per un'azienda leader
nel campo dell'automazione
e della robotica.
E qual è il mio compito?
Io sono il direttore dell'Academy,
sono responsabile della formazione
di 9.000 persone nel mondo;
e al contempo sono responsabile
di aprire le porte dell'azienda
verso i giovani, verso l'esterno.
Qui mi vedete con la camicia bianca,
nella cerimonia di conclusione
di un executive master;
ma è un'esperienza di ascolto
che ho anche la fortuna di vivere
tutti i giorni in famiglia.
Ho quattro figli - ahimè, tutti maschi:
avrei tanto voluto la femmina -
e sono disponibile allo scambio,
[se] qualcuno avesse
una figlia femmina da darmi.
E ho tre figli:
Francesco, Giacomo, Filippo,
e il piccolo Tesfa, che abbiamo deciso
di adottare dall'Etiopia,
e che vedete in braccio.
I miei ragazzi,
come tutti i giovani, oggi,
frequentano un sistema di istruzione
che fatica ad affrontare la sfida
della conoscenza correlata
all'evoluzione tecnologica.
Correlata come la quarta
rivoluzione industriale
sta cambiando, totalmente,
la nostra vita personale e professionale.
Sì perché le nuove tecnologie
dell'intelligenza artificiale,
dell'additive manufacturing,
dell'Internet of Things
e della robotica collaborativa
stanno davvero cambiando
il nostro vissuto.
E soprattutto il modo con il quale
le aziende ideano, producono,
e distribuiscono
i propri prodotti e servizi.
Per lavorare con queste tecnologie,
servono nuove competenze,
nuove mentalità, nuovi mestieri.
Serve allora un nuovo
"perimetro formativo",
come ho scritto nel mio libro,
che metta in connessione nuovi soggetti -
i giovani, la scuola,
l'università e l'azienda -
ma che sappia mettere anche in connessione
nuovi oggetti di apprendimento:
la tecnologia, le discipline scolastiche
e la cultura del lavoro.
La storia che vi racconterò oggi
è una storia di come le academy aziendali
stiano favorendo queste connessioni,
e di come, anche grazie
a dei manufatti innovativi,
stiano riuscendo a creare nei giovani
le competenze del futuro.
Iniziamo quindi dalle connessioni
tra nuovi soggetti di apprendimento.
Alcune iniziative, che sono espressione
di queste connessioni,
sono quelle destinate ai giovani talenti,
e perché no anche ai professionisti.
Alcuni esempi?
Il patentino della robotica:
oltre la certificazione delle lingue,
la certificazione informatica-
Un'iniziativa bellissima,
realizzata dalle accademie aziendali
insieme agli insegnanti, è questa:
mettere a disposizione un programma
per offrire ai giovani
di dotarsi delle competenze
di uso e programmazione
di un robot industriale.
Sono già 5.000 i ragazzi
che in Italia sono entrati
a contatto con questa certificazione.
Quando avranno 18 anni,
potranno lavorare
in una fabbrica con 1.000 robot,
e guidarli e programmarli.
Un'altra iniziativa frutto
di queste connessioni
è una summer school:
project and people management.
Eh sì, perché in questa
evoluzione tecnologica
dobbiamo gestire progetti,
essere molto bravi nel gestire le persone.
Dieci giorni a Shanghai,
Detroit o Belo Horizonte
per acquisire questi metodi e strumenti.
E di nuovo, è realizzata da chi?
Da un'academy aziendale,
insieme all'università.
Ma l'iniziativa che più
ci riempie di orgoglio
è un corso di laurea dal titolo
"Innovation and Technology Management".
Qual è la novità?
È che nello stesso banco
sono seduti ingegneri,
sono seduti i laureati in fisica,
psicologi, sociologi, antropologi;
e ottengono una laurea interdisciplinare
a proposito di connessioni.
E sì, perché questa
quarta rivoluzione industriale
non deve essere guidata
solo dagli informatici
e dagli ingegneri, ai quali
voglio un sacco di bene;
ma dev'essere guidata
anche dagli psicologi,
dai sociologi, dagli antropologi:
dagli esperti dell'uomo!
Perché possano cogliere
tutte le opportunità
dell'evoluzione tecnologica
cercando di mitigare i rischi.
Ecco alcune iniziative per i talenti:
ma ci sono iniziative, anche,
per i giovani che sono già in azienda
Sette anni, ormai. che viene realizzato
questo master, "Manufacturing 4.0",
dal Politecnico
e da un'accademia aziendale.
I ragazzi entrano in azienda,
li si paga un master sin dal primo giorno:
ogni mese, tre settimane
di lavoro e una di Master,
erogato non solo
dai docenti del Politecnico,
ma dai Subject Matter Expert dell'azienda.
E un'ultima iniziativa,
espressione di queste connessioni,
è un Executive Master
dove più di 40 dirigenti,
provenienti da tutta Europa,
stanno acquisendo le competenze
tecnologiche e gestionali
per guidare questa trasformazione.
Ecco quindi realizzato
il nuovo perimetro formativo,
dove i ragazzi non sono fruitori passivi
di servizi erogati dagli altri:
ma sono protagonisti dell'innovazione.
Dove la scuola, l'università,
non si limitano a fornire
teorie e modelli,
ma si immergono all'interno
della realtà aziendale, della realtà vera;
e danno il loro importante
e prezioso contributo.
Un nuovo perimetro formativo,
dove l'azienda non rinuncia
alla propria ambizione
di creare e diffondere cultura
e di trasferirla alle nuove generazioni
con quel DNA tipico
dell'identità aziendale:
quell'imparare facendo,
e quell'imparare relazionandosi.
Vorrei ora raccontarvi
di altre connessioni,
di altre connessioni tra oggetti
di apprendimento, discipline scolastiche,
tecnologia e cultura d'impresa.
Tutto nasce quando abbiamo iniziato
a sviluppare questo robot:
eravamo chiusi, in un laboratorio,
insieme a tanti giovani
e tante persone più esperte.
E mentre eravamo lì, abbiamo detto:
Beh, facciamoci guidare da tre principi:
vorremmo che questo robot fosse modulare,
fosse aperto - era un'innovazione aperta -
e fosse semplice da utilizzare.
E mentre eravamo lì,
presi in questo laboratorio,
in questo garage,
siamo andati a visitare
un'academy aziendale
che ha avuto un'idea intelligente:
ha creato un progetto
dal nome "la fisica in moto".
Ha detto: usiamo le motociclette
per attrarre ragazzi
e insegnare loro quanta fisica
c'è dentro una motocicletta.
E poi abbiamo pensato
alla nostra generazione,
quella del passato millennio,
perché le motociclette erano
un simbolo della nostra generazione:
io e tanti miei amici siamo cresciuti
con tre passaggi fondamentali:
14 anni, 16 anni e 18 anni.
Questi sono i passaggi
che hanno scandito la nostra vita.
A 14 anni, cosa c'era?
il motorino, il cinquantino:
avere il Ciao, avere il Sì
era un traguardo fondamentale.
Superato quel traguardo,
c'erano i sedici anni:
il patentino della motocicletta, il 125.
Io avevo un Cagiva Elephant!
Preistoria.
E finalmente, a 18 anni,
la patente e la macchina.
Su questo aspetto generazionale
voglio raccontarvi un aneddoto
della mia famiglia.
Io e mia moglie
eravamo pronti ad affrontare
le richieste dei nostri figli
rispetto a questi tre passaggi,
e quindi, a 14 anni,
ci eravamo preparati per dire a Francesco
le motivazioni per le quali
non avremmo mai comprato una motocicletta.
Abbiamo fatto una lista -
come quella di Lorenzo - pronti:
Francesco, non te la compreremo mai
per questo, per questo, per questo.
Pronti.
A 14 anni, Francesco
non è venuto a chiederci nulla.
Abbiamo detto: furbo Francesco,
vuole il 125, aspettiamo due anni.
Teniamo il foglio, l'abbiamo salvato
in una cartella speciale,
e a 16 anni eravamo lì.
Francesco non ne è venuto
a chiederci nulla, neanche a 16 anni.
Abbiamo detto: cavolo,
questo vuole la macchina,
vuole una macchina lunga
da qui fino alla fine del palco!
18 anni, niente.
Abbiamo dovuto mandarlo noi
a scuola guida,
per evitare di occuparci
di servizi logistici, il sabato sera.
E questo cosa ci dice?
Che le nuove generazioni sono attratte
da valori e da oggetti diversi,
ovviamente, dalla nostra generazione.
Sono attratti dai tablet, dai telefonini:
casa mia, la sera, è un fare divanismo,
ognuno con il proprio tablet,
o con il proprio telefono
su Facebook su Instagram.
Questo è il presente, e chissà il futuro.
E allora, mentre sviluppavano quel robot,
abbiamo provato a dire:
ma il robot non è ancora
più affascinante di una motocicletta,
per attirare le nuove generazioni?
E così abbiamo proseguito dicendo:
usiamolo non solo per fare coding,
per fare robotica:
ma per fare matematica, per fare fisica,
per fare quelle materie STEM
che sono fondamentali del futuro.
E abbiamo costruito
quella che noi chiamiamo
una "Robo-Experience" intorno al robot:
una serie di esperienze
che mettessero in connessione
i giovani e il robot.
Laboratori, centri, eventi, programmi:
e questo breve filmato
vi fa vedere una di queste iniziative.
[Centro di Apprendimento e.Do -
Un ambient Educativo Innovativo]
[SI IMPARA: Materie di scuola, Soft skill
e cultura del lavoro, con la robotica]
[4 FOCUS: STEM, Robotica,
Soft skill, Cultura del lavoro]
[ISPIRARE]
[DIVERTIRSI]
[APPRENDERE]
[PIANO DI LEZIONI]
[Benvenuto / Introduzione alla Robotica/
Materie di scuola con e.Do / Valutazione]
[Benvenuto]
[Introduzione alla Robotica]
[Materie di scuola con e.Do -
Divertiti con e.Do]
Metti in pratica le materie di scuola]
[Materie di scuola con e.Do - Usa e.Do]
[Valutazione]
Ecco questo è un esempio
di uno di questi centri
dove sono passati, pensate,
più di 10.000 ragazzi;
ma il nostro sogno è un altro.
Il nostro sogno è arrivare
a posizionare un robot in ogni scuola,
per contribuire a innovare la didattica
e aiutare le nuove generazioni
ad essere protagonisti del futuro.
Eccola qui, la magia: non è un robot,
ma sono i nostri ragazzi.
Sono un insegnante,
un facilitatore, un robot,
degli oggetti semplici, di legno,
che il robot muove;
ma che muove nella realtà,
non all'interno di uno schermo virtuale
dove i nostri ragazzi
già passano fin troppo tempo.
E poi c'è un tablet.
E sì, perché questo robot
è semplice da utilizzare.
La robotica sta vivendo quello che accadde
ai personal computer negli anni 80.
Vi ricordate che negli anni Ottanta
solo se eri un esperto di informatica
potevi usare lo Spectrum
o il Commodore 64.
Oggi invece i robot sono -
anzi, i computer sono
nelle case di ciascuno di noi.
Ebbene, la stessa cosa
sta accadendo ai robot.
Fino ad oggi serviva
un programmatore, per guidarli:
oggi, anche i nostri bambini
Andrea, Alessia, Federico
possono utilizzarlo
senza nessun tipo di corso.
E sì perché c'è questa interazione
che è la stessa che abbiamo
nei nostri telefonini, questa interfaccia,
che con un solo dito ti permette
di comandarlo e di muoverlo;
ma c'è anche un'evoluzione in più,
può essere programmato con blocchi.
Quindi con quel pensiero
e con quel linguaggio
logico-computazionale
che aiuta a mettere in fila le cose.
E poi, certo, gli informatici
che vogliono sbizzarrirsi, tutta la vita.
Che tipo di attività vengono proposte?
Come avete visto nel video,
innanzitutto lo montano:
ragazzi, ritorniamo a usare la manualità!
E poi? E poi ci giocano!
L'imparare facendo, così importante
dal punto di vista pedagogico.
ma anche andragogico.
E poi affrontiamo
e risolviamo dei problemi
che implicano l'utilizzo
della matematica, della fisica.
Matematica?
Qualche esempio: la somma,
la sottrazione, le equivalenze,
le figure geometriche che i bambini
delle elementari, come Alessia,
studiano tutti i giorni a scuola
beh, con e-Do è ancora più divertente
e ancora più efficace;
ma anche per i più grandicelli.
Qui abbiamo Federico:
la geometria analitica,
le equazioni di primo e secondo grado,
ecco a cosa servono!
Non per risolvere degli esercizi e basta,
ma per far muovere un robot nello spazio.
Abbiamo quindi vissuto tante esperienze,
abbiamo capito alcune cose:
uno, che questo robot favorisce
la partecipazione e l'inclusione.
Anche i bambini con dislessia, con ADHD.
Anche il mio piccolo Tesfa,
che ha un cromosoma in più, è disabile,
ma è bravissimo nell'utilizzare
questo robot, e questo è importante.
Ma poi, favorisce l'applicazione
delle materie alla realtà, l'inclusione,
e soprattutto, favorisce
anche la diffusione
di questa cultura del lavoro
che è tanto preziosa:
lavorare in team; tenere tutto in ordine;
risolvere problemi; essere creativi;
avere pensiero critico,
e anche mettere in connessione
la dimensione cognitiva,
quella manuale e quella emotiva.
Vorrei chiudere
con una frase di Walt Disney:
[Se puoi sognarlo, puoi farlo.]
Ecco il nostro sogno:
mettere in connessione nuovi soggetti
e nuovi oggetti di apprendimento;
ma soprattutto ascoltare i giovani.
E ho scelto di chiudere il mio intervento
con la foto di mio figlio Tesfa,
che sta ascoltando J-Ax.
Perché non dimentichiamoci
che i protagonisti del futuro sono loro.
(Applausi)